[Music]
what about just throw to the general
feeling right now that the the media
companies Twitter and and YouTube and
Google that there is some sort of
censorship happening related to their
algorithms or you know banning certain
people like you know Twitter for example
they they banned Milo but you know
they'll have you know the all right
Richard Spencer's on there and verified
again you're up to comment on the
specifics of that but just the general
like these companies are so close to
government right now and this is our
information highway right here this is
toughy this is where I might use that
line that I mentioned earlier I think I
set me up with yep but it's it's not
because I couldn't have an opinion but I
feel like I would have an obligation to
actually sit down with people who work
at Facebook Twitter and these places
because I know a lot of people at all
these companies and have a real factual
discussion about what's going on at this
point I do think at the very least if
we're gonna deal with banning or
preventing certain types of people from
voicing their opinions there should be a
consistent playing field it shouldn't be
moving goal posts so the rules should be
clear from the outset and they should
apply to everyone and there shouldn't be
one off exceptions I think in most cases
when we get into algorithms and what is
reward and what is not there are always
unintended consequences of the best
design whether that is an algorithm or
if there's an incentive structure right
I mean if you incentivize any of your
workers let's say within an organization
with certain types of sales quotas and
bonuses and so on they're always going
to be sort of perverse side effects of
those incentives that's always the case
so I think that it's in a way it's it's
on one hand rational and important that
we have high standards for how people
how people serve and curate data so that
we're not proliferating fake news and
that that can't be used as a weapon of
propaganda in a very damaging capacity
simultaneously I think it's unreasonable
to expect that all these gigantic
companies who are dealing with
technology and platforms of a scale that
is incomprehensible to most people who
aren't sitting down and being shown what
it looks like on some level by say an
employee of Google it's hard to even
fathom what being Google means that's
Sunrider to expect them to get all the
details right all the time it's an
evolving system so they're gonna make
mistakes and it's good to hold them to a
high standard but difficult to expect
perfection as they try to improve it so
so that I would I would put safely in
the category of I'm gonna reserve
judgment till I have more information
I think that was a pretty solid answer
for reserving judgment I mean you still
gave me something there how do you
decide who to trust when you're getting
your information you're talking to
people from I mean in your case quite
literally every walk of life probably
that there is how do you decide who or
what or what news organization or
whatever else that you actually feel is
doing a fair impartial job I don't trust
organizations in general but I will try
to identify specific people and if I'm
really trying to do triage I will
identify people in my circle of friends
or in my network who may not be
specialists in the domain that I'm
looking at whether that's a Cancer
Research or fill in the blank
San Francisco local politics and and how
to most effective and proposition it
could be super specific I will reach out
to two or three of my friends who I
think will have already tried to vet
good sources of information or simply
good thinking so it could be people who
are good at interpreting the information
people who are acting as as human
aggregators and filters
I'll almost go out immediately to those
people for instance I very frequently
bump into people because I'm reasonably
involved with both current and former
military so I've spent time at the
Defense Language Institute in Monterey
certainly have a lot of friends who are
former military and you bump into a lot
of folks running around calling
themselves Navy SEALs
and a lot of them are exaggerating what
they've done there are some very very
legitimate folks and then there are a
lot of people who drive the legitimate
folks crazy because all they actually
did was pass buds we're never deployed
now they're running around selling navy
seal workout routines and getting book
deals if in a case like that I will
immediately go to two or three of my
friends for from that community and say
hey sniff test zero to ten how much
would you recommend I talk to this
person so it's a very hands-on process
I'm I start from effectively a place of
distrust with with any mass media
because the incentives are not aligned
with truth at all costs it they just are
not and unfortunately that's I think the
reality of the business models of many
of these companies so even the
individual participants however much
they may want to represent difficult or
to divulge and discuss difficult truths
are disincentivized from doing so
because it may be so nuanced that only
5% of the target audience will take the
time to understand it and discuss it but
when you're trying to monetize on a CPM
basis the number of slideshows you can
put on a website then you run into you
run into a conflict very quickly yeah so
that's unfortunate challenge of trying
to siphon news another thing that I'll
use and I have no affiliation with this
this is a program called nuzzle and use
easy e/l and what that will do is it
will aggregate the most shared stories
from the people I follow on Twitter and
it creates a digest I've say the top 10
stories that have been shared the most
by the people I have already selected to
follow and I found that very useful but
in at any point for instance right now
or near presidential elections really
within six months on either side
it's just 99 percent noise but at other
periods it can be a very very useful
source of pre filtered information from
folks I've already hand-picked to follow
on say Twitter so to pattern-matching
that's been that's been very helpful for
me yeah it's funny because I expected
and hoped that after the election we'd
have like a little bit of a lull with
politics one way or another and it's
almost like everything has just been
ramped up even more I'm curious when you
talk about you know picking some people
that you trust in things like that you
are also from Long Island and I've
mentioned on the show a couple times
before that one of my great joys over
the course of the election is that I was
involved in a group text with three of
my old childhood from middle school
friends and we sort of reconnected over
politics arguing all the time one of the
guys was a huge Trump guy one was a huge
bernie guy one was somewhere in between
and then me and I thought this these are
people I trust like I knew them from
childhood I know where they come from I
knew their families celebrated holidays
with them all of that stuff do you have
a couple people in your life like that
who I have completely diverging opinions
well diverging opinions but also that
you have that you have like the long
history from childhood that you that
maybe you're outside of what you do
normally that you can go to and be like
oh yeah what do you think about stuff
you know oh for sure for sure
absolutely I mean I just came back from
a bachelor party for one of my oldest
friends I've known since we were kids
and a very eclectic group of guys who
got to know one another before anyone
was really entrenched in a given career
or anything like that and it's very
refreshing to have I think in healthy to
have those friends who really
don't have there's no potential or at
least I don't think so with these guys
certainly not any type of ulterior
motive or professional motivation
there's just none of that BS and noise
and Static and nonsense so yes I do I do
have those folks for sure yeah how do
you deal with that part of it that
because of the nature of what you do and
the public persona around you people
must want things from you all the time
yeah oh yeah they do and it's it's a tax
that I've accepted I have to pay and it
I think it would be unreasonable for me
to complain about it since it is a
byproduct of public exposure which I've
opted into mmm-hmm
but it can be frustrating I mean there
are there are times when people will
approach me and they'll try to butter me
up for a few weeks and do me a but it's
always a tip-off when I start getting a
lot of unsolicited favors from someone
who doesn't want anything I'm like I bet
you're gonna send me a book in two weeks
that I don't want to read it with the
expectation that I'm gonna give you a
blurb I bet that's what's gonna happen
and lo and behold that's exactly what
happens so I've had to set policies that
allow me to turn off entire categories
of requests like yeah I don't do book
for words
I don't do book blurbs I don't do
fill-in-the-blank across-the-board
hundred percent just don't do it and
every once in a blue moon I'll make an
exception for someone I know really well
but it's very very rare or for instance
right now like I'm not doing startup
investing so if you think you're gonna
come to a conference and talk to me
about two or three things you found on
my Wikipedia page to try to develop some
rapport and then pitch me or startup at
the end of the night not gonna happen
oh man that's I was gonna hit you up
because you know we're growing pretty
rapidly here but a little seed money you
know what I'm saying and that happens
all the time
well I mean I've had I've had people in
San Francisco this is very unique to the
somewhat like Asperger's romanticizing
nation nature of Silicon Valley but I
mean I've had people I'm
sitting at a dinner with say a
girlfriend and they will literally come
up pull up a chair sit down and just
start pitching apropos of nothing no
intro no nothing I had one guy at South
by Southwest I've had at least 12 guys
try to pitch me while I'm standing at a
urinal which is not the right time not a
good thing you got a serious elevator
pitch at that point yeah it doesn't
matter how good your pitch is and it
goes on but I would say it's attacks
that that I've had to accept but I'm I'm
much more cautious about any open-ended
invite to have a conversation or a
coffee or a dinner so if someone says
hey could I introduce you to my friend
Joe he wants to grab a cup of coffee or
like would love to come to dinner with
us I'm like okay if Joe wanted something
from me what would it be
right what would you guess and I want to
know in advance like it's okay to have a
pitch but I want to know what it is
before hit yeah so that's that's how I
think of it these days all right well
let's let's finish up by actually
talking about your new book are you
willing to talk about your new book I am
willing I know it twist twist the arm
but I'll go for it all right let's see
what we can do here so tools Italian so
this is basically the collection of the
best ideas the best practices that some
of the most interesting people that
you've talked to over the past couple of
years have put into practice so I guess
the easiest question at first would be
is there is there just the general theme
with these heavy hitters with these
people who are doing it that we all
would want to emulate and be like and
learn from is what is the what is the
general theme yeah I'll answer that and
I would say also that the tools of
Titan's was really never intended to be
a book it was just a notebook that I was
compiling for my own use so this going
back over my own notes to grab the most
actionable routines and tools gadgets
anything that I could apply immediately
in tests from all these different guests
and one of the themes I would say that
that first it's split into three
sections and this is how a lot of these
guests think of
their lives healthy wealthy and wise and
the health is first because the the most
prolific thinkers and creatives in the
book have also come to highly prioritize
physical function and that manifests in
a lot of ways but for instance Rick
Rubin one of the most legendary music
Provisionals of the last 50 years
introduced me to something called the
chili pad which I won't get too far into
it but allows you to very precisely set
the temperature of the sheet that you
lay on in your bed and it's been a
complete game-changer for me many other
people and that also came up with super
athletes so you find a lot of
commonalities in the top 1% of multiple
fields in other words they have more in
common even though it might be chess
military strategist black market chemist
you name it the top 1% in all those
fields have a lot in common more so than
they have in common with the B players
in their own fields so that was really
cool to see all of them I would say are
very good at asking seemingly absurd
questions so so that that is a
commonality across the whole the whole
gang so you would have say they're a
bunch of billionaires in the book like
the Reed Hoffmans and Peter teals and
Mark and driessen's there's a lot of
folks Peter teal I think is a very good
example so he asks questions like and
I'm paraphrasing but why can't you
accomplish your 10 year plan in the next
six months right all right all right
that that's a very bold question and if
you're going to think on that and as
many people in this book do journal on
it and actually sit down and freehand on
that question for three pages let's just
say then you have to temporarily put
aside the constraints and assumptions
that have led you to where you are
because if it's your 10-year plan you've
set a timeframe and sort of an
incremental approach that doesn't work
at all if you're trying to cram it into
six months right all of a sudden you
have to come up with these very very
potentially outlandish and absurd
unconventional answers and what
what I've found also then that these two
go together is that so for instance
Larry Page co-founder of Google
mhmmm has said and I'm gonna paraphrase
this but what people miss about really
big audacious goals is that it's hard to
fail completely
so you'll very often fail above everyone
else's success even if it's only a
partial win so you find a lot of that
like Peter Diamandis chairman of the
XPrize who's working on all these
different exponential technologies and
spends a lot of time with people like
Ray Kurzweil James Cameron and so on
when entrepreneurs are pitching him to
try to get investment he will ask them
and I'm paraphrasing all of these but if
you had to 10x the economics of your
business in the next three months what
would you do and if their response is
that's impossible he responds with I
don't accept that answer try again right
so but but you get unusual output and to
find paths that are unique that are not
well trodden you have to ask better
questions so I'd say that's very very
common more than 80% of the people in
the book also have some type of
mindfulness practice which could take
the form of meditation say using a
guided meditation there's one that came
up a few times which is free called the
the 2010 summer smile meditation which
is by Tara brach super specific but that
one came out multiple times for instance
or people using headspace in the
mornings Arnold Schwarzenegger and ended
up using transmittal meditation for a
year twice a day and then saw benefits
for decades afterwards I was really wild
when you think about it other
commonalities so I asked almost all the
guests what book have you gifted most to
other people yeah there are certain
books that popped up over and over again
that are maybe lesser-known like poor
Charlie's Almanac by Charlie Munger
who's Warren Buffett's right-hand man
but who gets less of the media spotlight
because I think he quite frankly hates
being in the spotlight
he's pretty kin cantankerous dude but
incredible book that came up repeatedly
with some of the wealthiest people
Sidharth ax by Hermann Hesse came up
repeatedly by some of the best musicians
and investors go figure right so there
are sapiens was another one that came up
across the board repeatedly so these are
the types of things that you spot
there's some weird ones like males over
the age of say 45 very high percentage
of them don't eat breakfast at all or
only eat one primary meal two per day
usually an early dinner that came up a
lot so you have and that's that's
totally again vention ilysm right yeah
it's it's it's it's for the most part
runs completely counter to conventional
wisdom but if you look into the
scientific literature which I've done
even for females it looks it appears as
though there's some data to suggest that
as you get older you actually consume
protein for instance better in a single
large bolus a single large dose so
rather than having like a bodybuilder or
a meal every four hours or whatever it
is even three meals a day if you're a
seventy year old 80 year old you'll
actually consume your protein more
efficiently having the majority in one
meal and go figure so it seems to seems
to correspond but there's a bunch of
weird stuff like that that pops up over
no really have any of these Titans told
you something or giving you some wisdom
that you tried to put into practice and
then we're like man that does not work
for me well uh yes definitely and and
the good news is for every pattern
there's someone who will let you off the
hook that's that's that's the good news
so you can really the objective is to is
to create your own bespoke toolkit right
and for instance there are a lot of
people who wake up very early you have
people who uh Amelia Boone who's this
incredible super athlete jock a willing
long list of folks who wake up and say
4:30 in the morning so I've tried that
but I'm much better going to bed around
4:30 in the morning and so I I would
lean more
towards say the BJ Novak's you know
writers and comedians and so on who
can't even really hit their groove until
11:00 a.m. that's more my speed
but yeah the waking up with the Amish
not my thing
I can't can't I can't really make that
work for me not not anytime soon yeah so
do you think some of this is just how
you're hardwired versus how you can
actually learn to train yourself like
something like that I would guess that
knowing you you could probably overcome
that if you put enough time into it you
may not feel it feel that that's worthy
of putting time into but how much is
that battle between just the way you're
hardwired and nature versus the desire
to change yourself well I think you
think you can the good news is that
everything in Tulsa Titans is intended
to be a one-day or a one-week experiment
right so you can try it and I firstly
said something along these lines he said
accept what is useful reject what is
useless add what is uniquely Ron so I've
tried to do the morning thing and I'm
just better yeah going to bed late and
waking up late and I okay with that I've
accepted that I don't beat myself up
over it and there is definitely a
hardwiring component I mean some people
need only three hours of sleep per night
I know a bunch of these mutants the vast
majority the people will do best on say
seven and a half to ten hours of sleep
per night and I would say maybe thirty
percent of the people I've spoken to
they have to talk to about this we'll
try to get some type of short nap in the
same mid-afternoon like between kind of
2:30 and and and four o'clock so it's
it's there are certain personalized
elements that are dependent on your
genetic makeup or at least influenced by
our genetic makeup but I mean reality is
more negotiable than I think people
realize even that stuff you can override
it if you want to for periods of time
you can you can use something like
polyphasic sleep and combine that with
something called exogenous ketones it's
a powdered form of alternate energy
basically you combine those two things
you could probably do like two two and
half hours of sleep per day
for a few weeks at a time and I've done
that before in dire situations but it's
not something you want to try to sustain
yeah man I should I should have talked
to you about a month ago because I
could've used it this month all right
I'm gonna end this with the the most
softball question of all time if you had
one book that you wanted people to go
out and read right now go out and buy a
book you know what I mean Digital
hardcopy whatever it is what what book
would that be
I would I would have to recommend not
biased I would have to recommend tools
of titans because this is the first book
I enjoyed writing and it is the first
book that I have since writing reread
multiple times because the the tools and
tactics and recommendations are not just
mine it's not me listening to myself
this is the best practices of 200
world-class performers from every
possible discipline you can imagine and
as of right now in Amazon I think it has
410 reviews straight I mean it's a
five-star average it's like 87% of
giving it five stars come on I think I
know you're refreshing as we're talking
oh come on now oh oh oh yeah I know the
compulsive Amazon don't get me wrong
there's no author well I shouldn't say
no author no author I know who is immune
to that during launch week for sure you
haven't hit that level of peace yet you
know of high-level ya know during launch
week yeah every author is just like a
rat with a cooking pellet dispenser
checking Amazon if we're being honest
but yeah tools of Titan's is what I'd
recommend it's it's I think very
appropriate for all age levels
incredibly flexible gift there's
something in it for everybody and it's
really intended so you can sit down with
a cup of tea or coffee and get a chapter
in that period of time by the time you
finished that cup so it's it's a fun
book and very proud of it so if people
feel so inclined I would I would
encourage them to check out tools of
titans all right well you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna put the link
to tools Italians in the commenting
right down below and we will see if the
Dave Rubin effect is as powerful as the
Tim Ferriss
I can't can't wait to see it and people
can keep people can find retailers all
over the world if they want or you know
Amazon so on at tools of titans comm
they're also some sample chapters
forward from Arnold Schwarzenegger it's
wild so yes we will see we will see what
happens I'm looking forward to it all
right Manuel listen we did I think we
did over an hour here and I know you
only have a four hour workweek so I'm
very appreciative of your time you're
welcome my pleasure man all right thanks
to Tim Ferriss you guys can follow him
on the Twitter at Tim Ferriss the link
for tools of titans is right down below
and thanks for watching we'll do it
again next week
[Music]
you